the world is desperate right
[Music]
i think it's great i respect the two of
them and what they've done in comedy you
know i've been a huge fan of wandas
forever
amy is hilarious and so we just want to
make sure that it's a fun night that
we're celebrating movies people at home
people there live for watching and
really just having a good time
they're going to be shown certainly
they're going to be filmed before so
we'll still be able to celebrate you
know all those categories especially as
an artist knowing how important they are
it just was a matter of trying to figure
out what we could do to get the time to
three hours because a lot of people
outside of entertainment find that the
length of the show at three and a half
three hours 45 minutes felt too long so
it was a matter of trying to
see if we can get it
down to three hours but then also still
show all the winners of like you know
all those categories that we certainly
know we couldn't survive without them
don't let me not have hair and makeup
you know it's not going to work
so yeah we just want this night to
celebrate everyone so everyone the
audience will see
all of our winners